nous présente une programmation qui
augmente de 25% les crédits et pas
seulement en personnel en poste mais sur
beaucoup et surtout en investissement ce
qu'on demande depuis des années
l'amélioration des casernes de
gendarmerie des locaux de la police les
problèmes des véhicules le problème des
hélicoptères le problème des Canadairs
pour la sécurité civile toute une série
de choses nous avons demandé
sont présentés c'est donc une loi
systémique mais le gros sujet c'est que
pour nos compatriotes qui voient la
délinquance et la violence surtout
augmenter dans toutes les couches de la
société
la réponse ne peut pas être que
policière elle doit être aussi et
surtout judiciaire qui a quand même un
grand absent de ce débat c'est la
justice à Caen une
la loi d'orientation justice police
[Musique]
la première la réforme de la police
judiciaire
le ministre veut une
départementalisation de la police qui
travaille trop par si l'eau police de
l'ère des frontières la sécurité
publique la sécurité intérieure et la
police judiciaire nous nous disons que
la police judiciaire doit garder une
spécificité
premièrement elle doit rester évidemment
sous l'autorité judiciaire du procureur
dans tout ce qui est en quête
préliminaire et le préfet n'a pas à
connaître de ces questions là
deuxièmement elle doit garder les
affaires sensibles et le fait de
mutualiser des moyens entre la sécurité
publique et la police judiciaire ne doit
pas aboutir à ce que la police
judiciaire soit deux faite des saisies
toute une série d'affaires donc
on demande des engagements ministres
là-dessus deuxièmement dans le quotidien
feuilletons de cet été les rodées
urbains réponse apportée par la loi rien
de plus
feuilletons
de la rentrée depuis septembre les refus
d'obtempérer
72 refus d'obtempérer en moyenne par
jour en France plus 17% de piano
troisième chose les violences faites aux
élus locaux plus 57% depuis un an ce
n'est pas tolérable j'ai donc déposé un
amendement qui n'est pas dans le texte
du Gouvernement qui vise à réprimer
beaucoup plus sévèrement les refusants
tempérés et en particulier puisqu'on est
la chambre représentative des
collectivités locales qui donnent le
même statut à un élu local dépositaire
de l'autorité publique que un policier
ou un gendarme et donc toute personne
qui s'attaquera verbalement physiquement
avec des violences avec des menaces un
élu local encourera les mêmes risques
que de s'attaquer un policier ou un
gendarme
oui à plus de moyens ça fait des années
qu'on le demande oui à plus d'efficacité
oui à plus de numérisation de
digitalisation pour s'adapter à la
nouvelle délinquance mais il faut aller
beaucoup plus loin sur la justice
beaucoup plus loin sur le rétablissement
de l'autorité publique et pas seulement
faire des discours mais mettre des des
choses très claires dans la loi en
particulier renforcer les sanctions
contre tous ceux qui s'attaquent avec
violence au dépositaire de l'autorité
publique